[Music]
all right anything in my teeth as a
former professor who taught
entrepreneurship I often get asked what
are the secrets to good leadership
here's one piece of advice be nice now
niceness might seem like a naive
strategy especially in this climate it
feels like our society today has become
a battle of competing pessimism wouldn't
an actively nice leader seem out of
place but that's exactly the point these
days warm heartedness is radical and
unexpected and it turns out also very
effective and one 2013 study researchers
found that a positive kind leader is
judged to be 132 percent more effective
than an unpleasant leader now niceness
does not mean we need fewer
disagreements one less debate business
and policy require a healthy competition
of ideas but our intellectual contests
should be fierce and friendly at the
same time some leaders at night it will
help you build a sustainable success and
a better world to learn more about the
competitive advantage of being nice
click the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you
want ati scholars to cover in 60 seconds